et pour en parler en direct avec nous
josé espinosa il et j'ai les jambes
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors cela fait
trois ans et né le mouvement des gilet
jaune est-ce que la détermination et la
même
écoute et hier soir il y avait une
manifestation a montré qu' montrer
qu'effectivement la détermination non
seulement elle était la même mais mende
était encore plus
comment dire plus forte et c'est normal
d'ailleurs parce que les conditions de
vie de travail se sont aggravées
notamment avec la crise sanitaire qui a
été très mal gérée par le gouvernement
et aussi par les augmentations de prix
l'inflation
enfin tout ce qui est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre et notamment les
délocalisations la désindustrialisation
de la france on pourrait prendre
beaucoup de domaines dans lesquels la
france est en train de péricliter et de
décliner et malheureusement il s'agit
maintenant de des merciers la tendance
mais on verra ça dans les mois qui vont
venir puisqu'il y est il va y avoir les
élections présidentielles qui vont
peut-être amené un chargement plus je le
souhaite justement vous espérez quoi une
résonance particulière du mouvement des
idées jaune à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
mais le mouvement des gilet jaune qui
depuis trois ans de manière
ininterrompue mène son combat aura
forcément des incidences sur le plan
électoral bien sûr parmi les gilet jaune
une partie
encore assez importante ne veulent pas
voter ou en tous les cas se désintéresse
un peu de la lutte dans les urnes mais
une autre partie a fait des pas
importants dans la prise de conscience
qu'il s'agissait maintenant de faire un
choix et donc je crois qu'il sera fait
je ne sais pas encore
dans quelle mesure et dans quelle
direction mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
les choses ne resteront pas en l'état
alors trois ans de mobilisation c'est
l'heure du bilan justement quel bilan
faites vous que votre relation avec
emmanuel accroc avec le gouvernement
c'est que des promesses ont été faites
il y a trois ans est ce qu'elles ont été
tenus selon vous est ce lui ment pas il
savait qu'il ya eu le grand débat
beaucoup de gilet jaune d'ailleurs se
sont moqués du grand débat je crois
qu'ils avaient raison parce que du grand
débat il n'est rien ressorti et les
quatre mesures qui avaient été prises en
décembre 2018 là aussi
aucune mesure sérieuse n'avait été mise
en oeuvre puisque nous a fait croire
qu'on allait toucher un smic élevé 200
euros par mois ce qui était évidemment
pas le cas ensuite on nous a dit qu'on
allait dit fiscaliser les heures
supplémentaires mais là aussi ça n'a
touché que très peu de monde ensuite on
leur a dit qu'il y allait y avoir des
mesures qui étaient prises pour
développer des comment dire
créer les conditions d'un environnement
meilleur alors on a eu la convainc t on
a eu la coupe en six on voit bien que
rien ne se passe je crois que alors sur
le plan démocratique alors là on voit
bien qu'il ya un totalitarisme qui est
en train de subvertir notre pays et donc
tout ça bon c
c'est un peu le tableau des lignes
il ne se passe rien de sérieux et je
crois que les gilets jaunes ont eu
raison de mettre en avant le départ de
mac ronge et de la macro ni parce que
c'est pas que macron c'est tous ceux qui
sont autour je crois que il faut aller
dans cette direction là et que les
élections permettront de se débarrasser
de ses gouvernants qui n'ont rien
entendu ils sont restés soit et qu'il
reste encore et il le demeure prenez la
question des hausses des prix des
carburants et osseux des prix des
produits alimentaires et bien
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent ils proposent
que ce soit nous qui nous payons
l'augmentation mais non c'est pas comme
ça il faut bloquer les prix
si on veut une mesure sérieuse il faut
bloquer les prix pour que ce soit les
profiteurs de situation qui paye et ce
n'est pas le cas c'est passé par tous
les cas les mesures que prend le
gouvernement
je n'ai espinosa vous êtes gilet jaune
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france